eight days into office and another
challenge for president joe biden
left over from the trump era immigration
reform biden removed the ban on
travelers from several muslim majority
countries on his first day in office
immigration rights activists want him to
do more
quickly rescinding the muslim ban is the
floor
not the ceiling and if justice is going
to be served it has to be served for
all of us
[Music]
they want those brought to the us's
children to remain
and be given permission to work
something that was allowed
under president obama this also calls
for wider
immigration reform i've been separated
from my family too and that like
it's crazy it drives me crazy and
president biden said it in his
inaugurational speech
it's time to be bold so i called you out
preston
biden and vice president harris to be
bold
and closer detention centers to be bold
and reunite families now
today people cannot be there anymore
far away from washington at the u.s
mexican border
former president donald trump's policies
are still in place
those seeking asylum under trump were
detained in the u.s
and sent back across the border to wait
for their outcome in mexico
a process that can take months or even
years
we hope that those who have been put in
remain in mexico will be able to make
their asylum cases
from the safety of the united states and
outside of detention
but again we haven't seen uh follow-up
action from the biden administration on
exactly what's going to happen
so there's a lot of uncertainty on the
part of those in the remaining mexico
program
around 65 000 people were returned to
mexico during the trump administration
biden's white house says the program
will stop but there's no clarity on what
will happen to those
still in detention the people
don't send me back i ask you please to
look at me i am guatemalan and you will
see that things are tough over there
there is no work there is crime i can't
take it anymore
that's why i have come here i have a
family here and that's why we are
looking to cross
i came by bus it took a month to come
here by bus
just a little more than a week after
coming into office
president biden faces many expectations
from americans
and those who wish to become one in the
near future
hamara chaudhary al jazeera